so this is the page introduction to big
data information you can all open it up
as well and this has the schedule
similar to that which we have already
discussed and then we have some other
participants who have completed the
course and then there are three
different licensing systems so this one
month program can be joined and you can
get access to all of the things that we
discussed at only 45
subscription to the program and then you
will have project courses and project
library and then certification and all
of this so it would be best if i can
explain this via a document that we have
prepared so let me do that and show you
the entire thing but this is a page
where you can you know proceed with your
application here you have to select an
option for example if i have to select a
basic subscription
then i will select this option it will
take me to the payment page where i can
complete my registration feed processing
and then we will i'll get the access to
all of the resources that are mentioned
and get the schedules and the
calendar invite and all of that
specifically it's a pretty simple
process now let me show you a document
so
this is a document that has all the
compilation of the resources so this is
the program
if you can see my screen and then this
is the payment link and this is the
registration link so once you have
registered and showed we have shared
with you the zoom link for the session
and then this is the program
registration page and these are the
sessions which are scheduled
and every week we will be going through
one of these technologies in detail and
covering different aspects that we
discussed in today's webinar so after
completing this what are the different
opportunities so designing a
bioinformatics research which we
discussed did not discuss in so much
detail but we'll be in the session so
there's a registration fee associated
with the registration to this program
and why this is there's a registration
fee because you will get access to the
online tutorials premium courses project
examples cloud pipelines r and python
coding sessions session recordings live
group sessions and certificates and
project proposals so this is included in
the beginner license and then we have
the intermediate license where you can
have a one-on-one mentorship mentorship
when you want and if you have to clarify
doubts that you will be available for
that and in the advanced license you
will get get one month additional time
to complete some of the courses and
get additional support from sorry 15
days extension to get
the support uh
the task
then
once you are doing this what are the
benefits why why you should do this
other than the benefits of learning you
will get an opportunity to have your own
profile on the learn so you have already
created login you will get your own
profile this profile is showcased to the
collaborators and it can be showcased by
you to show your certificate so the
program says that you have completed the
courses that you have done so once you
complete a course so i said genomics if
you completed genomics you will get a
certificate to complete for completion
of genomics and that you have trained in
genomics
similarly that is a co-certification
that you will get other than that you
will also get a program certification
once you complete the session and mark
them on the learn page and on points you
will be able to earn this
certificate by the end of the program
and as i'm telling you that with each of
these courses you will finish you'll get
five or six certifications for finishing
the courses here also and we have some
scholarships for locust programs for our
partner universities and organizations
so we have partnered with many
universities across globe including
ones in india and so if you're a student
in one of those partner universities you
can reach out to us and you can get
additional scholarship
and you can also request for scholarship
in that sense we have a
kind of
online call with your references that
you can you know that you put in your
scholarship request and once you confirm
uh about the need then we give you the
scholarship associated partial
scholarship because it's already a low
cost program and we have a lot of
resources allocated with it and we would
want you to make the most of this
opportunity however
if you would be interested in
if you are interested in joining as a
group then there's a possibility of you
to gain scholarships uh and
uh discounts for joining a program so
these are some of the resources that we
put together for this program and we'll
be happy to share with you uh
any other questions that you have answer
any other questions that you have so
please feel free to ask your questions
now and we are open for a q a session
to answer questions from zara she is
asking any research funding
opportunities yeah if you have a
research proposal and then you can
submit the research proposal to uh
via uh an email you can write to me you
can write to dr harpreet and share your
research
and based on the research proposal we
can provide scholarship for the research
fellowship program which is a different
program this one where we are developing
research projects and that comes once
you have gone through this sort of
training where you know the application
of different type of data sets and you
have done through onto the uh example
projects or
data sets that gives you a clear edge
when you're doing your own project to be
able to completely understand and finish
your project
so i think this is what we wanted to
share with you today and please feel
free to reach out to us with this email
addresses or you can reach out to our
team online through slack through skype
and through whatsapp and telegram
so we'll be happy to help you out with
any of your questions and
yes this program will be conducted in
by a group in
in uh in nigeria so this will be
available for african participants
through eureka collaboration and this
program will be available
uh you know in
the sprint month so we were planning to
do this quite frequently because we
understand that there is a lot of
uh need to get started to begin with and
this is the one of the best way we could
find
we can find to start uh to start working
with you and to collaborate with you to
help you with your research with your
learning and to develop skill sets for
opportunities such as job opportunities
internship opportunities and all of that
so lisa you have a question you said
that the courses sections are available
prior to our training how does that work
so once you register if you register
if you're registering it today today if
you're registering today you will get
access to the courses and all the
material from today onwards so you have
a good amount of time left
before the start of the program and each
of the sections that we are going to
cover so you'll have always have
opportunity to finish those ahead of
time for uh to come up with questions
and to come up with doubts during the
session where we will be more happy to
resolve those doubts resolve your
questions
make you understand how this is applied
and how this is done so
this that's the opportunity and i hope
that i've been able to answer your
question lisa
also like it is something that you can
do at your own luxury at your own time
because i think the courses are pretty
much accessible through your mobile
phone
also i mean your ipads so you can do
that and for
uploading data and stuff like that on tv
server we would recommend you to use a
laptop so another benefit is the online
infrastructure that has been avoided
that has been provided with this
fellow with this program
yeah